[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines au programme de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici les titres de ce
mardi 23 à 23 mai
le rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
femmes de la pop culture c'est le
geek-up festival ce week-end de
l'événement revient pour une deuxième
édition au Clayes-sous-Bois un festival
qui mêle jeu atelier animation et
rencontre avec notamment des acteurs de
la saga Harry Potter on en parlera avec
nos invités le traitement médiatique de
la banlieue est-il juste c'est le thème
central de la pièce et c'est un
sentiment qu'il faut que nous
combattions je crois à mi-chemin entre
le théâtre et le documentaire cette
œuvre nous plonge dans la vie d'une
rédaction télé et nous questionne sur
notre vision des quartiers populaires
David Fargeon son metteur en scène est
notre invité et puis apprendre à
respirer se relaxer prendre le temps de
développer ses sens en bref revenir à
soi chose qui n'est pas toujours très
simple Cloé berger naturopathe et
sophrologue vous propose chaque mois des
sophro balades qui mêlent marcher
exercices de relaxation dans la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye découverte
et puis au tour du plateau avec moi des
invités ma compagne tout au long de
cette édition Jérôme révèle bonsoir
alors vous êtes le président de
l'association geek Up Family avec vous
on va parler du festival qui se tiendra
aux Clayes-sous-Bois les 27 et 28 mai
prochain donc c'est un rendez-vous
incontournable pour les fans de la pop
culture mais justement qu'est-ce que
c'est que un rassemblement autour de la
pop culture qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait y
retrouver alors vous pourrez retrouver
tout le tout le week-end de samedi à
dimanche des exposants qui seront
présents des animations des cosplayeurs
des cosplayeurs professionnels qui
seront présents aussi tout le week-end
et tout ça sous un soleil magnifique
normalement tout le week-end donc c'est
la pop culture c'est pour les grands
comme les petits et justement juste pour
noter les spectateurs qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un cosplayeur c'est un c'est
une personne qui crée son costume par
rapport à un univers qui le fait de A à
Z et je vais prendre l'exemple de la
500e French garnison qui sera présent
tout le week-end une armure complète de
stromtrooper vaut environ une fois que
tout est fait par les par les
cosplayeurs pas loin de 3 à 4000 euros
voilà et vous serez justement tout à
l'heure accompagné de Geoffroy cotoné
que le trésorier de l'association on en
reparlera plus amplement dans quelques
instants à vos côtés David Fargeon
bonsoir alors vous êtes le metteur en
scène de la pièce de théâtre c'est un
sentiment qu'il faut que nous
combattions je crois alors dans cette
pièce le spectateur est plongé dans
l'univers dans dans les coulisses en
fait d'une rédaction télé et en quelques
mots d'où vous est venu l'idée de
réaliser cette pièce de théâtre et bien
on va dire ça fait une grosse dizaine
d'années que la compagnie des gens
urbaines existent et que ça fait une
grosse dizaine d'années qu'on
s'intéresse à la banlieue comme un enjeu
de récits de mise en récit et donc on
s'est intéressé à l'urbanisme on s'est
intéressé à l'architecture et avec la
classe politique disons que le
journaliste est un gros pourvoyeur de
récit sur pas banlieue et que c'est un
récit qui ne s'assemblait passionnant à
aller analyser titiller et votre pièce
sera jouée ce vendredi 26 mai à l'espace
Coluche à plaisir on y reviendra
également dans quelques instants pour en
parler plus en plus de vous Marreau de
Rouvray bonsoir bonsoir donc vous êtes
la chargée de production du spectacle
secret défense au Château de Rambouillet
alors ce spectacle immersif plonge le
spectateur au coeur de la rencontre
historique entre le président américain
hansenhower et le général de Gaulle en
1959 alors c'est un spectacle qui se vit
au fur et à mesure des pièces visitées
par le spectateur il y a également des
admissions de public qui sont faites à
peu près toutes les 10 minutes donc
j'imagine que c'est quand même beaucoup
d'entraînement de répétition est-ce que
vous en êtes aujourd'hui dans dans les
répétitions et dans les préparations à
cet événement vous avez bien résumé
l'événement secret défense actuellement
nous venons de commencer le montage du
spectacle donc qui de ce qui commencera
le vendredi je vous dis 2 juin prochain
donc dans quelques jours finalement
les répétitions des de tous les
participants touchent à leur fin on a
une autre dernière répétition générale
le 13 mai dernier et puis on commence du
coup à installer les décors à doucement
installer les coulisses tous les
portants de costumes les accessoires les
etc
et on est plutôt serein et on avance
doucement mais sûrement pour pour que
tout soit parfait pour le jour J ben en
tout cas on le souhaite on y reviendra
aussi plus en détail tout à l'heure et
pour terminer ma petite Franck ou
bonsoir bonsoir Régine que vous êtes la
journée enfin journaliste également de
la rédaction TV 78 et avec vous on va
faire le point sur l'actualité à ne pas
manquer dans les Yvelines et puis dans
cette édition on parlera aussi des Dark
kitchen donc ce sont des cuisines de
restaurants partagés qui sont destinés
uniquement aux livraisons et aux clics n
collecte on partira également à Cannes
grâce à nos confrères de chez Radio
sensation ce soir Martin patrie mais à
l'honneur des musiques de films et enfin
comme chaque mardi nous recevrons
Véronique Ithurbide chroniqueuse chez TV
78 pour nous parler des infos insolites
dans les Yvelines alors voilà le
programme est rempli mais juste avant de
le dérouler je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
du soleil en veux-tu en voilà le ciel
sera voilée Lucienne justement sera très
ensoleillée dès demain au réveil il sera
généreux sur tout le département il fera
10 degrés à Rambouillet et 11 degrés à
Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie et dans
l'après-midi le ciel justement sera
voilé sur tout le territoire côté
température prévoyez 18 degrés en
moyenne sur tout le département et
demain nous fêterons la Saint Donat
Donatien le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence ces informations du jour
Mathilde avec une victoire pour les
défenseurs de la cause animale tout à
fait Régine souvenez-vous en juillet
2019 l'usine d'épuration le SSIAP avait
subi un incendie cette incendie avait
provoqué le déversement d'eau non
traités dans la Seine suite à cette
incident près de trois tonnes de
poissons morts avaient été repêché à
proximité du site l'association Paris
animoso police avait alors porté plainte
ils ont eu récemment gain de cause le
tribunal administratif de Paris a
ordonné aussi app de communiquer l'audit
de sécurité qui avait été effectué alors
au lendemain de la catastrophe
industrielle grâce à cette audit
l'association souhaite identifier ce qui
est ce qui a causé la mort de ces
millions de poissons et faire en sorte
que cela ne se reproduise plus et
direction à présent carrière sous Poissy
la mairie lance une consultation
concitoyenne citoyenne inédite quel
avenir pour la mère de déchet voilà la
question que souhaite poser la mairie de
car sous Poissy aux habitants lors de
cette consultation citoyenne pour rappel
la mère de déchets représentait la plus
grande décharge à ciel ouvert de France
aujourd'hui les 26000 tonnes de déchets
ont été nettoyés se posent alors la
question de la réhabilitation de cette
plaine entre carrière sous Poissy
Triel-sur-Seine Andrésy ou encore
Chanteloup-les-Vignes planté une forêt
installer des panneaux photovoltaïques
créer un lieu dédié au vélo ou implanter
un centre d'éducation animale voici les
quelques pistes qui seront présentées
aux citoyens ils pourront donner leur
avis jusqu'au 7 juin sur le site de la
mairie on poursuit avec le chiffre du
jour 10000 pourquoi Mathilde c'est le
nombre de cendriers de poche qui seront
distribués dès aujourd'hui au buraliste
de Versailles alors concrètement dès
qu'un versaillé ira acheter un paquet de
cigarettes il se verra remettre un
cendrier de poche gratuitement
l'objectif évitez que les mégots
envahissent la ville et pollu nos
rivières au total 24 buralistes
participe à cette opération cette action
s'inscrit dans la campagne propreté
lancée par la ville depuis le début de
l'année
touristique et une grande ville c'est
une ville préfectorale aussi on a un
très bon retour sur de propreté sur
cette ville donc c'était normal que on
poursuive avec les mégots on aille plus
loin même parce que pour l'instant les
mégots étaient sont toujours ramassés
par les balayés par les agents mais je
pense que le fait de dire aux gens
attention il faut aussi avoir un geste
écologique un geste citoyen ou même type
que les déchets mégot est un déchet donc
au même titre que les déchets il faut il
faut éviter qu'ils se retrouvent sur la
voie publique on recense tous ces lieux
qui sont effectivement les lieux de
regroupement de personnes donc les
tabacs les terrasses les devants les
lycées ça peut être aussi le cas
les parents parfois en attendant leurs
enfants à l'école mais tous les lieux de
regroupement et de stagnation font que
effectivement on a des
ces différents gisements de mégots qui
qui restent sur le sol
alors cette initiative est une première
dans les Yvelines elle est rendue
possible grâce à la contractualisation
de la ville de Versailles avec la
Fédération des buralistes
d'Île-de-France et celle des Yvelines
ainsi que l'écho-organisme d'alcool ce
que les gens ignorent c'est quand ils le
lancent sur le trottoir en fait ça va
partir la plupart du temps dans le
caniveau ça va être emmené en fait dans
les eaux usées et ça risque de terminer
du consulte dans la rivière et dans la
mer où ça aura une pollution vraiment
identifier ce sujet pour tous nos
commentaires donc consommateurs qui
doivent vraiment ne plus dans un premier
temps jeter et commencer prendre
conscience que ce mégot n'est pas un
c'est un produit synthétique c'est un
produit industrialisé donc il faut y
prendre garde
en France ce sont 7,7 milliards de
mégots qui sont maljetés chaque année
les co-organismes alcool a donc pour
objectif de réduire ce chiffre de 40%
d'ici 2027 et si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un job d'été vous avez des
pistes à nous proposer Mathilde oui
Régine la Poste recrute 580 saisonniers
dans toute l'île de France pour cet été
il s'agit précisément de 500 facteurs et
de 80 opérateurs de colis les contrats
sont soit des CDD ou des contrats en
intérim et s'étale de juin à septembre
La Poste recherche des personnes de plus
de 18 ans avec le sens du service et un
bon esprit d'équipe aucune condition de
diplôme n'est exigée il est juste
nécessaire d'être titulaire du permis B
si vous êtes intéressé vous pouvez
postuler dès à présent sur le site
internet www la poste recrute.fr et
enfin on termine avec un peu de sport et
en particulier avec du tennis et oui on
va s'intéresser à Roland-Garros Régine
livelinoise Margot Rouvrois c'est
qualifié second contour des
qualifications la jeune de 22 ans
s'entraîne à plaisir et s'est imposé en
1h39 de jeu face à la championne Sofia
Quenin une performance Sofia Konan était
finaliste de Roland-Garros 2020 et
vainqueur de l'Open d'Australie 2020
également pour son premier Grand Chelem
Margot Rouvroy démarre donc de la
meilleure des manières elle devra
affronter la biélor la biélorus Irina
shimanovic au premier au prochain tour
une autre victoire du côté des femmes
yvelinoises la versaillesse Chloé paquet
s'en sort bien également à la éliminé
l'espagnol Rosa witzens mas elle
continue donc les qualifications jeudi
prochain elle affrontera une autre
espagnole à Liona bolsova et du côté des
hommes moins bonne nouvelle notre
yvelinois Antoine guibaudeau a été
vaincue par le Slovaque Norbert gombos
le rambolitain avait gagné le premier
set mais s'incline finalement pour
rappel il avait reçu une invitation pour
les qualifications du tournoi et bien
merci beaucoup à Mathilde pour les
informations du jour et comme d'habitude
si vous aussi vous êtes témoin d'une
actualité près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous le partager sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
et direction maintenant Saint-Cyr
l'école où nous sommes partis découvrir
une dark kitchen aussi appelée cuisine
fantôme essentiellement destinée à la
vente à emporter ces restaurants ont
fleuri après le confinement mais que
valent-ils exactement réponse en images
avec Gabriel Gontier 4 restaurants dans
un seul lieu c'est assez inhabituel et
pourtant c'est ce que propose cette
établissement de Saint-Cyr-l'École
bonjour bienvenue au maki family premier
en son genre dans la ville cette dark
kitchen ou encore cuisine de l'ombre est
essentiellement destinée à la vente à
emporter vous avez le homaki le Jungle
food le pepino et le Bubu Chica c'est
des restaurants qu'on avait à Versailles
on a tout concentré à Saint-Cergue
sur les cartes les spécialités
africaines sont à l'honneur et se
déclinent sous toutes les formes le
principe de la Dark kitchen c'est
d'avoir plusieurs enseignes au même
endroit et pour loger ses enseignes il
faut beaucoup de cuisine giuseppedo
c'est le gérant nous fait la visite vous
avez tout ce qui est bibi chic à tout ce
qui est galette qu'on travaille ici
les milk-shakes un petit peu préparation
là nous allons dans la partie secrète
on y va au sous-sol cuisine réserve ou
encore chambre froide
la préparation que ce soit nos sauces
le poulet le poisson tout est préparé
ici avec trois cuisiniers le gérant
prépare chaque jour des plats
exclusivement fait maison au total une
vingtaine de repas vont sortir des
cuisines ce midi avec une majorité de
commandes reçues sur cette tablette je
suis en train d'imprimer le ticket de la
commande du pépino donc c'est un afro
Burger et philochet oui passe par la
plateforme de livraison
uber eats donc voilà ticket en plus des
services de livraison de plats cuisinés
le restaurant a créé sa propre
plateforme pour commander sur le site
alors on a développé un click and
collect du coup on peut directement
aller sur l'anglais commander
là on va retrouver du coup les quatre
cartes en fait du restaurant la
spécificité de ces nouveaux restaurants
leur présence repose essentiellement sur
Internet et les plateformes de livraison
qui représentent entre 60 et 70% des
commandes
en quelques clics seulement la commande
est passée il ne reste plus qu'à
réaliser le burger le plat devrait être
préparé en une vingtaine de minutes
avant le passage du livreur
souvent perçu comme de la restauration
rapide et de basse qualité avec leur
restaurant les gérants souhaité créer un
concept de qualité ça dépend des
établissements c'est à dire que nous on
est on essaie d'être à l'image de notre
de notre cuisine c'est à dire qu'on
travaille comme l'islam nous a dit avec
quasiment avec des produits frais mais
voilà ça dépend il y en a qui vont il y
a d'autres qui travaillent je veux dire
la plupart c'est du surgelé nous on
essaie d'être le plus en équation avec
le monde de maintenant de travail avec
de faire tous mes ongles que ça soit les
boissons les jus les sauces voilà pas
mal de choses mais ça veut pas dire
darkishon ne veut pas dire malbouffe
c'est-à-dire beaucoup de personnes qui
font de la street food mais pas
forcément de bonne qualité nous on veut
donner de l'amour gustatif une dark kit
Chen pas si sombre qui pour garder un
aspect chaleureux et du contact propose
également des places assises comme dans
un véritable restaurant
allez c'est maintenant l'heure d'ouvrir
une page culture
[Musique]
et on parle à présent de pop culture
après une première édition en 2022
l'association geek-up revient revient
les 27 et 28 mai prochain au
Clayes-sous-Bois au programme jeux de
piste concours de cosplay animation Just
Dance tout un tas d'activités pour
captiver les fans de la pop de culture
alors Geoffroy cotonay que vous êtes
venu en plateau nous rejoindre vous êtes
le trésorier de l'association geek-up
festival et à vos côtés on le rappelle
Jérôme Prevel alors première question
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver à
ce festival est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui change par rapport à l'an
dernier alors oui il y a des choses qui
changent par rapport à l'an dernier
l'année dernière nous avions eu trois de
voix de doublage en présence tout le
week-end que cette année nous aurons
deux acteurs de la saga Harry Potter qui
seront présents tout le week-end donc
Josh Herman et Louise cordis qui sont
les acolytes de Drago Malefoy dans
l'univers d'Harry Potter surtout dans
l'épisode 7 et l'épisode du 8 on peut
voir d'ailleurs à l'écran oui
nous aurons comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la seinième french garnison qui
est l'association
labellisée par Disney qui représente
l'univers de Star Wars nous aurons deux
cosplayeurs professionnels qui habitent
plaisir qui seront présents tout le
week-end aussi pour être jury du
concours de cosplay et apporter leur
aide et faire des panels nous aurons une
artiste allait nous aurons donc des
dessinateurs ainsi que des auteurs qui
seront présents tout le week-end
justement pour revenir sur ses acteurs
qui seront présents qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont faire exactement ce qui a une
dédicace une séance de dédicace des
conférences comment ça se passe alors
oui c'est ce qui est prévu donc les
visiteurs vont pouvoir donc prendre leur
ticket pour rencontrer ces deux acteurs
et donc soit prendre juste une photo
avec eux soit sur signer un petit
autographe discuter un peu avec eux et
puis surtout à pouvoir les voir sur
scène et donc on a des généreux
bénévoles traducteurs qui sont là pour
aider ceux qui ne parlent pas forcément
anglais pouvoir passer leurs questions
nos micros pour que du coup les acteurs
puissent y répondre
comment est-ce que vous avez réussi à
les faire venir au festival on s'est
toute une histoire de contact il faut
juste avoir le numéro des bonnes
personnes c'est très simple non c'est
faux
c'était assez difficile donc le monde de
comment de ce genre de manager de
contrat est très petit donc une fois
qu'on a trouvé en contact après on
apporte est ouverte mais il faut réussir
à trouver le contact et c'est pas
forcément simple en tout cas vous avez
réussi donc c'est une très belle chose
vous avez aussi parlé d'exposants il y
aura donc de nombreux artistes des
peintres des illustrateurs qu'est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir comment ça se passe
alors dans les dans l'artiste
effectivement pour faire simple donc
notre tête d'affiche entre guillemets
c'est Monsieur Philippe Tessier qui est
l'auteur créateur de l'univers de
Polaris donc qui est un univers et à la
base de jeu de rôle qui a été ensuite
exploité en le plateau en roman et ainsi
de suite nous avons aussi au niveau des
illustrateurs donc qui barre donc qui
est le pseudonyme qui travaille pour
Marvel et qui fait en fait les premières
de couverture et l'illustrateurs de
couverture il a travaillé sur des
numéros comme spawn pour ceux qui savent
et nous avons aussi du coup son son ami
on va dire Gaël qui lui travaille sur
les sagas Spider-Man et Hulk donc pareil
pour vous avez sûrement déjà vu ces
dessins si vous lisez des comics voilà
vous avez aussi des artistes des
Yvelines de partout en France on
travaille avec la librairie JMS de
Fontenay-le-Fleury qui notamment a fait
venir
Natacha Godot qui du coup une autrice
jeunesse qui adapte énormément de choses
notamment beaucoup de livres de la saga
Pokémon pour les enfants
cette année vous en attendez combien
on espère plus
au moins le double pour cette deuxième
édition et surtout que nous avons nous
allons avoir de beaux stands à proposer
en partenariat avec Cultura de des
Clayes-sous-Bois ainsi que centrale
comique
qui est sur Paris du coup pour l'année
dernière c'était déjà un très bel
objectif j'imagine pour nous oui c'est
comme c'était la première on n'avait pas
mis la barre haute on s'était dit c'est
la première on verra comment ça va
comment ça va prendre pour la deuxième
effectivement on a on a mis un peu les
bouchées doubles on va dire de notre
côté c'est ça donc suivant les
recommandations que nous avons reçues
donc
normalement on devrait être bon pour
cette deuxième année et on peut déjà
vous annoncer que il y aura sûrement une
troisième fois
justement que sur votre site on voit
aussi que vous souhaitez faire des dons
à des associations à des associations
chaque année l'an dernier vous aviez
fait un don justement restaurant du
coeur cette année vous avez déjà une
idée de l'association à laquelle vous
voulez
tous les ans effectivement quand on fera
les festivals nous choisissons une
association qui nous tient un cœur
personnellement dans le dans les membres
du bureau donc cette année pour tout
oublier d'entrée acheter un euro est
reversé à la Ligue contre le cancer
d'initiative et alors justement comment
est-ce que on peut s'inscrire ce qu'il
faut le faire à l'avance est-ce que on
peut aussi arriver sur place et
vous oui vous pouvez venir sur place
vous pouvez aussi le prendre sur la
plateforme et l'oiseau de la commande de
l'événement ça revient exactement au
même les tarifs sont les mêmes et à la
fin on aura juste besoin de Biber votre
petit billet et bien chez nous et les
prix justement pour avoir une idée pour
annoter les spectateurs
5 euros une journée 8 euros le week-end
merci Jérôme et Geoffroy d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc on disait tout à
l'heure le geek-up festival revient les
27 et 28 mai prochain aux Clayes souvent
aux Clayes-sous-Bois au parc de Diane
et puis on va faire un petit saut dans
le sud de la France à présent à
l'occasion du 76e Festival de Cannes TV
78 grâce à Radio sensation vous emmène à
la Croisette ce soir ce sont les
musiques de films qui sont mises à
l'honneur on va rencontrer deux
compositeurs Robin Coubert et Pierre Le
Feuvre ils ont travaillé sur l'un des
films de la sélection officielle avec à
l'affiche livinois Guillaume Canet on
retrouve sur place Martin à Patry
l'envoyer spécial de Radio sensation
Robin Coudert alias robe a composé la
musique originale d'acide un film
catastrophe de juste Philippot présenté
au Festival de Cannes dont voici tout de
suite quelques images
c'est difficile de qualifier cette
musique parce qu'on essaye toujours
spécialement dans les films de genre
d'être original d'être expérimental
d'aller chercher des choses qu'on n'a
pas peut-être l'habitude d'entendre
ailleurs en tout cas on a essayé d'être
à la fois spectaculaire intimiste
à l'armiste peut-être c'est un film
profondément dur donc j'essaye d'être
toujours voilà du côté des personnages
de leur affection c'est à 10 ans que
Robin Couderc commence à expérimenter la
musique électronique il découvre le
cinéma 12 ans plus tard en composant le
premier court-métrage de sa femme pink
cowboy boots et en fait j'ai assez vite
compris que ma musique se prêtait assez
mal au jeu on va dire commercial au jeu
des radios au jeu de la promo parce que
c'était une musique un petit peu hors
format hors cadre et que j'avais du mal
à la vendre et donc du mal à en vivre et
puis le cinéma est apparu dans ma vie un
peu comme une forme de Mécène c'est à
dire que tout d'un coup
cette qualité qui était un dans la pop
musique devenait une grande qualité pour
le cinéma c'est à dire une musique
singulière exigeante particulière
peut-être trop original pour la radio
mais suffisamment pour le cinéma la
musique du générique d'acide à quant à
elle était composé par Pierre Lefeuvre
alias CIC c'est une musique qui est
faite comme son indique pour sortir les
auditeurs du film en fait il y a une
vraie il y avait une volonté de juste le
réalisateur de d'aller sur une note un
peu d'espoir sur une autre couleur en
fait et après le ce que ce que a pu
poser robe sur sur ces images il voulait
aller sur sur une autre sonorité une
sonorité peut-être un petit peu plus
ouais qui portait sur un peu plus
d'espoir peut-être sur un peu plus de
lumière ah si d'un film de juste
Philippot avec les musiques de Robin
Couderc et Pierre Lefeuvre dont la
sortie en salle est programmée au 20
septembre
et je vous donne dès à présent
rendez-vous demain pour un nouvel
épisode sur la Croisette on parlera
cette fois-ci de l'Observatoire de
l'audiovisuel européen et on revient
maintenant dans les Yvelines au Château
de Rambouillet le spectacle immersif
secrets défense produit par Polaris et
les monuments nationaux proposent de
revivre la rencontre historique entre le
président américain Eisenhower et du
général de Gaulle au Château de
Rambouillet en 1959 alors Mao deux roues
de Rouvray justement c'est la deuxième
édition de ce spectacle pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne connaissent pas
secret défense est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire découvrir un peu justement ce
spectacle immersif bien sûr secret
défense c'est un spectacle
immersif et historique avant tout c'est
un spectacle hors du commun c'est c'est
une aventure un parcours spectacle que
nous invitons le spectateur à vivre au
sein du Château de Rambouillet l'idée
c'est que le spectateur est invité à
revivre
un sommet d'État qui s'est réellement
déroulé en 1959 là on retrace en effet
la rencontre entre les présidents
Eisenhower et de Gaulle qui s'est
réellement déroulé au sein du Château de
Rambouillet du coup le 3 septembre 1959
et donc on
immerge le spectateur
je veux j'essaye de pas de pas en dire
trop pour donner aussi un petit peu un
petit peu de suspense mais voilà on
invite les visiteurs à assister au
coulisses d'un sommet d'État donc en
passant par des bureaux d'écoute des
services secrets français
en assistant à une réunion entre les
conseillers du président américain et en
bien sûr un moment rencontrant les les
fameux présidents français et américains
et comment justement vous avez fait pour
retracer ce qui s'est passé en 1959 vous
avez fait appel à des archives comment
comment ça s'est passé tout à fait alors
ça c'est le travail de Charles mollet le
metteur en scène et auteur du spectacle
qui a donc passé des mois à à retrouver
des archives en effet d'époque donc il
s'est inspiré de le spectacle est
entièrement inspiré de faits réel après
on y apporte notre pâte un peu fictive
et magique pour avoir cette part de
spectacle mais en effet tout ce qui est
dit on peut totalement le retrouver dans
des archives d'époque donc c'est des
documents écrits à la machine à écrire
c'est des photos c'est c'est tout un tas
d'archives en effet qui ont aidé à
écrire ce spectacle de bout en bout et
jouer dans des
décors naturels est-ce que ça présente
des difficultés supplémentaires comment
comment est-ce que vous gérez ça
justement bien sûr oui ben on peut pas
faire forcément tout ce qu'on veut on
est quand même dans un château donc qui
est un monument historique donc on doit
s'adapter au lieu et donc après tous les
tous les décors sont faits en fonction
des lieux donc parfois on s'adapte à
chacune des pièces au matériau qui sont
présents et on
c'est là aussi que la magie opère de
notre côté parce que on arrive à à
recréer des choses en construisant
totalement des décors et surtout qu'il y
a aussi 600 bénévoles donc ça fait quand
même complètement bien sûr sans eux le
spectacle n'existerait pas le spectacle
et entièrement enfin tous les
participants de ce spectacle de son des
volontaires donc on est en compte entre
près de 600 sur ce spectacle qui sont
donc toutes les personnes que vous allez
croiser en venant voir ce spectacle
c'est-à-dire les personnes qui sont à la
à la billetterie à l'accueil qui sont à
la buvette du spectacle qui sont dans
chacune des pièces qui sont en coulisses
également ce sont tous des des
volontaires à l'oeuvre depuis trois mois
maintenant et est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi s'être intéressé justement à ce
point de l'histoire
[Musique]
beaucoup près d'un an et on a repris en
bah non je dis ça mais plus puisque la
première a été deux ans plus tard donc
pendant deux ans le spectacle a été à
l'arrêt mais on a on a des participants
qui sont restés très fidèles et qui
étaient déjà là en 2020 qui se sont
réinscrits les dernières qui sont
toujours là cette année et qui nous
suivent mais du coup le spectacle devait
commencer en 2020 et la première du
spectacle a eu lieu en juin dernier 2022
et alors justement on va s'adresser
aussi aux téléspectateurs qui sont en
famille est-ce que les enquêtes est-ce
qu'il me semble que quand on est
visiteurs spectateurs en tout cas de
secret défense on entre dans la peau
d'un agent d'un agent secret est-ce que
les enquêtes que doivent mener l'été
spectateur est-ce qu'elles sont
accessibles pour les enfants est-ce que
c'est simple c'est compréhensible alors
c'est il y a des termes c'est un sujet
de toute façon qui plutôt destiné aux
adultes ou au lycéen qui aborde cette
période là sans aucun souci les enfants
je pense que il y a de toute façon une
période magique parce parce que il y a
des décors absolument extraordinaires on
fait monter on propose à une partie des
spectateurs de montée à bord d'une
voiture du cortège présidentiel donc on
fait tout un tour dans les dans les
allées du château avant de commencer le
spectacle et voilà donc les décors les
les musiques les le jeu des acteurs tout
ça je pense par là absolument tout le
monde et je pense qu'on a tous une part
d'enfants en nous qui fait que petit ou
grand on aime on aime ce spectacle
justement ça sera le mot de la fin merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation Mao on
le rappelle donc vous revenez pour 4
weekends donc au mois de juin et ça
démarre dès le 2 juin au château d'or
Rambouillet alors justement vous aviez
reçu 18000 spectateurs l'an dernier donc
on vous souhaite de faire pareil voire
même plus et donc voilà beaucoup de
beaucoup de bonnes choses pour pour ce
mois de juin merci à vous
et on va maintenant parler d'une toute
autre oeuvre donc c'est celle-ci n'est
pas immersive mais elle permet toutefois
au téléspectateur pardon de voir les
coulisses de la télévision alors David
Fargeon vous êtes le cofondateur de la
compagnie légende urbaine et vous êtes
metteurs en scène de la pièce c'est un
sentiment qu'il faut que nous
combattions je crois alors cette pièce
propose je cite ce que j'avais trouvé
aussi c'est de démonter le mythe d'une
certaine vision de la banlieue portée
par les médias aujourd'hui quel constat
vous faites justement à l'égard de la
couverture médiatique des banlieues
aujourd'hui
je m'attendais pas celle-là non mais
parce non mais non très sincèrement je
m'attendais pas à ça parce que
effectivement nous on le document qu'on
utilise principalement et qu'on analyse
tout au long du spectacle il a dû 2016
donc il a il a un certain nombre
d'années aujourd'hui
et que aujourd'hui moi je regarde plus
du tout la télé mais comme beaucoup de
personnes enfin que le rapport aux
médias il a il a vraiment il a vraiment
beaucoup changé
le bâton parce que justement vous
regardez plus la télé par rapport
justement à ça ou c'est pour autre chose
non ça fait évidemment partie des
raisons et
mais après je pense que c'est aussi une
évolution de consommateur d'informations
voilà entre les réseaux sociaux les
nouveaux médias etc ou on n'est plus
là-dedans mais moi lou ça me semble
intéressant de de de revenir de revenir
comment fonctionne le journal alisme
télévisuel c'est que il est un peu à la
matrice aussi d'une façon de produire de
l'information d'une façon de produire du
regard de et de fabriquer du récit et
que sur les chaînes d'infos on continue
sur certaines d'entre elles en tout cas
avec un axe éditorial voir idéologique
assez clairement d'un côté de
l'échiquier politique
Marsa vient pas de nulle part en fait et
de là Mao parlait
d'un spectacle qui revient sur un
événement historique et qui essaye de
décrypter par l'archive etc là on est
sur un événement sur sur une histoire un
peu moins ancienne mais c'est toujours
intéressant je trouve de revenir aussi
voilà à l'origine nous moi je date on
aime bien qu'il a date de 81 pour
commencer à parler de ce qu'on nomme le
mythe médiatique des banlieues 81 c'est
les mainguettes c'est les rodéo des
mainguettes à Vénissieux c'est ce qu'on
avait nommé l'été chaud des Minguettes
et c'est à partir de ce moment là où
pendant un mois et demi on voit des
voitures brûlées dans la banlieue de
Lyon pendant un mois et demi tous les
soirs au journal de 20 heures et que ça
ça va profondément marquer un imaginaire
collectif et ça va ancrer quelque chose
d'une image de ce que serait les
banlieues françaises de ce que serait le
quartier populaire français marqué par
voilà des voitures qui brûlent déjà qui
sont potentiellement dangereux du
désœuvrement de l'immigration de tout un
tas de thématiques
dont on sature aujourd'hui mais qui
était déjà très présente il y a plus de
40 ans alors pour réaliser cette pièce
de théâtre vous décidez de recréer cet
univers de la télé avec de la lumière
des caméras un plateau pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez fait ce choix alors ce
choix il est fait parce que moi ce qui
m'amuse au théâtre c'est que on est sur
un art finalement relativement archaïque
de fabriquer de la représentation on a
un plateau des acteurs des spectateurs
qui sont en face de nous et à partir de
là on va jouer des personnages on va
fabriquer du décor euh alors à l'inverse
de fabriquer du décor avec trois francs
suisses et moi ça m'a et ça ça m'amuse
beaucoup ça et ça m'amuse d'autant plus
quand on peut aller convoquer un autre
vocabulaire et que ben là le vocabulaire
qui est utilisé sur ce plateau là le
type de lumière le type de rapport qu'on
a vous et moi les caméras qui sont qui
sont là la manière dont en régie ils
vont décider de faire le montage etc etc
et ben tout ça ça va produire de la
forme produire du récit et nous le fait
de réutiliser ce même dispositif sur
scène c'est à dire que sur scène on a
effectivement trois caméras on a un banc
de montage vidéo on monte à vue on filme
et on monte à vue pendant le temps de
l'arthentation c'est les comédiens qui
le font et Ben et ben du coup on peut
s'amuser à
déconstruire la façon dont sont
fabriqués des représentations et voilà
il y a quelque chose de très ludique
là-dedans finalement et si on revient un
peu plus justement sur l'histoire de
cette pièce
déjà il y a combien de comédiens sur
scène et qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir y
apprendre en regardant cette pièce alors
on est si comédiens sur scène parce que
je joue dedans également on est six au
plateau
et en gros moi j'aime à dire qu'on fait
du tas de documenté c'est à dire que on
fait un théâtre ou
11 documents beaucoup on lit on lit
beaucoup enfin on essaye de s'emparer un
sujet le journaliste on n'est pas
journaliste aucun d'entre nous n'est
journaliste donc on prend un vrai temps
pour se documenter sur cette profession
et sur les modes de production de la
formation etc
mais là où je dis documenter c'est que
pour moi c'est important que les acteurs
les actrices
d'où on parle
moi si je si je travaille depuis plus de
15 ans sur la banlieue c'est en tant que
banlieusard et que ben moi en tant que
banlieusard
j'ai envie de de proposer d'autres
récits que les récits dominants et que
tous les acteurs les actrices du
spectacle ils viennent pas tous de
banlieues mais par contre ils ont tous
un regard et leur regard il a été
façonné justement par les médias
et donc il y a
le spectacle qui est vraiment décomposé
en 5 chapitres et chaque chapitre est
ponctué par un solo d'un acteur ou d'une
actrice qui raconte qui met en jeu d'où
elle d'où elle parle et je pense à
enfin je pourrais en citer plusieurs
mais
il y en a ou ben la comédienne nous
explique que elle elle arrive en région
parisienne elle vient de Provence et
elle arrive en 2005 elle arrive en 2005
elle est étudiante en 2005 elle débarque
à Paris et qu'est-ce qu'elle voit elle
voit les émeutes et elle se dit et dans
un truc qui sature qui est ultra
anxiogène et qui se dit et ben voilà
elle arrive là et d'un seul coup elle
arrive dans cette ville et et il y a un
cap entre ce qu'elle vit ce qu'elle voit
à la télé et que ça ben voilà ça c'est
un truc ben voilà ça raconte tout ça par
exemple et justement vous parlez de
façonner le regard
j'imagine aussi que pour la jeunesse qui
regarde la télé ils peuvent avoir aussi
cette imaginaire collectif et ce qu'en
gardant votre pièce un jeune peut-être
de un jeune adolescent peut comprendre
facilement la pièce et pouvoir
conscientiser aussi le message que vous
que vous souhaitez faire passer
ouais c'est un spectacle on l'a créé en
2019 lui aussi il a été interrompu par
le covid etc mais bon ça fait un certain
nombre d'années qu'on tourne et
qui fonctionne très bien avec les
lycéens qui fonctionnent très bien avec
avec les collégiens on va dire à partir
de 3e et qu'on a des bords plateaux des
échanges des ateliers en classe avec
avec les élèves
on sent que il y a
il y a quelque chose il y a quelque
chose qui qui se produit et et un
échange et une rencontre et aussi qu'on
qu'on intervient dans des classes
de quartiers plus ou moins populaires
de se dire qu'à un moment donné
c'est un spectacle j'espère qu'on essaie
de rendre une certaine dignité à cette
jeunesse là qui qui peut par moment se
sentir un peu stigmatisé un peu pointé
du doigt et de leur dire mais en fait
ça fait du bien ouais ça fait du bien
vous existez et vous pouvez être aussi
les acteurs de vos propres progressifs
vous pouvez aussi raconter
vos histoires et à votre manière bien
merci David Fargeon d'être venus chez
tv78 pour nous parler de votre pièce de
théâtre on le rappelle et ce jour à sur
la scène de l'Espace Coluche à Plaisir
vendredi 26 mai du coup ça parle de
notre neutralité et une thématique qui
nous est chère en tant que journaliste
merci à vous comment se reconnecter à
soi et à la nature une sophrologue et
naturopathe propose des activités de
sophro balade quatre fois par mois dans
la forêt de Saint-Germain-en-Laye alors
ça se fait par petits groupes et les
participants sont invités à éveiller
leur sens au cours d'une marche
consciente entre couper de séances de
sophrologie une pratique visant à se
relaxer tout en profitant des bienfaits
de la nature un reportage réalisé par
Julien Leroy
et puis vous allez penser à toutes les
tensions que vous pouvez accumuler dans
une journée
se reconnecter à son corps au milieu des
arbres depuis le début du printemps des
balades associées à la sophrologie sont
proposés dans la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye cette discipline
de relaxation née dans les années 60
visa améliorer son bien-être en
rééquilibrant son corps et son mental
organiser quatre fois par mois c'est
sorti permettent de combiner les
bienfaits apaisants de la nature à cette
pratique psycho corporelle j'ai vraiment
ressenti un besoin de se reconnecter à
soi-même chez les percer les gens on a
quand même vécu des années qui sont
difficiles et il y a un besoin de sortir
de rencontrer du monde
local à la respiration est haussez les
épaules
chasser toutes ces tensions du haut des
épaules et souffler par la bouche
relâchée
bloquer la respiration décontraction du
visage des trapèzes ou du ventre ces
exercices en groupe visent à se détendre
pour prendre conscience des crispations
éventuelles pendant qu'on marchait j'ai
senti que je respirais pas de façon
régulière donc c'était intéressant de
constater ça et de pouvoir le
rééquilibrer je me suis senti centrée
aligné dans mon corps
et ça fait du bien qu'on a tendance à
être hyper connecté hyper tout va très
très vite on oublie qu'on a un corps et
qui a qui ne fonctionne pas au même
rythme et à avec la même force que le
mental donc il faut en prendre soin
apprendre à se reconnecter avoir des
moments de calme un travail sur les sens
dans cette balade consciente vue oui et
toucher exalté pour profiter de
l'instant présent dans un environnement
naturel je m'aperçois que on marche en
faire trop attention ou sensation au
bruit au son au contact avec le sol
ça évite d'être trop dans la tête de
redescendre dans les pieds du coup ça
dépend beaucoup en parallèle des
sophrobades adressées aux parents et aux
enfants sont proposés sur le thème des
émotions ou du corps l'occasion
d'apprendre à développer sérénité et
connaissance de soi dès le plus jeune
âge
et on va terminer cette page culture
avec les insolites de Véronique
et pour commencer les informations
insolites on prend la direction de la
vallée de Chevreuse vous allez nous
parler de folie lavoir qu'est-ce que
c'est alors c'est une association qui
s'appelle hélium qui regroupe un certain
nombre d'artistes il se trouve que du 27
mai au mois de septembre jusqu'au
journée du patrimoine la vallée de
chevaux et plus précisément les lavoirs
des villages de la vallée Chevreuse vous
pouvez être investie par 35 artistes 32
l'avoir alors ils vont sûrement se
disputer un peu il y en a pas assez mais
on se débrouille et c'est financé par il
faut le dire par la Région Île-de-France
et puis le PNL et puis les communes
c'est sur 27 communes et ça s'appelle
fulli lavoir donc le lavoir est au
centre du travail de l'artiste qui
s'approprie le lieu alors vous aurez
différents matériaux des fautes la photo
du sculpture qu'est-ce qui existe pas
sur aidez-moi Land Art etc vous aurez
aussi alors le 28 mai si vous voulez
voir les artistes ils seront tous chacun
en
alors la voir vous aurez aussi après
d'autres événements qui vont se greffer
à savoir des vernissages comme ça dure
longtemps tous les thés des vernissages
des concerts des spectacles il faut
vraiment regarder le programme ça va
être très riche il y a quatre c'est
organisé en quatre parcours 3 sur les
Yvelines 1 en Essonne pour vous donner
un espèce de logique de de cheminement
certains l'avoir sont assez proches les
uns des autres donc vous pouvez y aller
soit à vélo soit à pied et puis et puis
l'avoir c'est c'est un endroit qui est
important enfin qui était surtout
important autrefois une fonction sociale
de mystique ça peut parler aussi de la
condition féminine de l'environnement
naturel voilà voilà
de beaucoup de choses et donc ce sera à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 septembre jusqu'au
17 septembre complètement il est à
partir du 28 mai très bien très bonne
date aussi faut préciser pour votre
deuxième information à celui de
Véronique vous êtes aussi intéressé à
l'une des plus meurtrière de l'histoire
oh meurtrière la pauvre Charlotte Corday
alors Charlotte Cordesse une jeune
normande aristocrate et prise d'idées
révolutionnaires complètement outré
écœuré par la tournure que prend la
révolution à savoir la terreur et les
massacres elle pense que Mara et un des
principaux responsables et elles montent
à Paris pour l'assassiner ça c'est voilà
alors sur elle a une lettre qu'on l'on a
retrouvé et qui va être vendu dans la
maison de vente au Sénat qui est un
département
royauté qui est départ d'un je change de
paquet de feuilles département royauté
dans le responsable et Robin gauguayo
qui m'a donné plein d'infos extrêmement
intéressant dans cette lettre elle va
être mise à prix entre 80 et 100.000
euros c'est net manuscrite elle appelle
ça appel aux Français amis des lois et
de la paix c'est une pièce autographe de
Charlotte Corday alors elle a donc
assassiné le 13 juillet 1793 marins d'un
coup de couteau dans le cœur arrêtez
tout de suite elle a échappé au lynchage
cette mise en prison le 17 juillet l'été
jugé par fouquetainville qui a fait pas
lui mais les autres révolutionnaires ont
fait disparaître cette lettre parce que
on voulait pas croire qu'elle était
indépendante on voulait faire croire que
c'était un complot de des Girondins et
en fait non elle était vraiment
indépendante et elle ce qu'elle disait
aux Français c'est attention vous voyez
comment ça tourne ressaisissez-vous
récupérer vos libertés arrêtons la
violence elle elle était pour la paix et
elle a mis des lois et de la paix quoi
et donc c'est sacrifié et elle disait de
toute façon tuant un homme j'en sauve
100.000 et cette lettre aussi elle est
très émouvante parce qu'elle est donc de
sa main il y a du titre d'épargne que ce
qu'elle avait accroché caché dans son
corsage et un acte de naissance aussi
parce qu'elle se dit sur le chemin si si
Marie malheur au moins on sera qui je
suis et elle dit bien je suis seule à et
de responsable en acte n'allez pas
embêter mes parents ni ma famille et et
voilà donc elle est exécutée et cette
lettre va être mise en vente comme j'ai
dit entre 80 et 5000 euros sachant que
la lettre n'en avait déjà parlé de
Robespierre à Danton est parti à 225 000
euros voilà ça peut s'envoler c'est un
document extrêmement touchant très bien
et vous vouliez également nous parler
des prochains Vy alors demain j'ai le la
joie le plaisir et l'honneur de recevoir
Michka sayas pour la deuxième fois
jusqu'à Azaya c'est un journaliste
spécialiste de musique rock il officie
tous les soirs sur France Inter il vient
de sortir un livre qui s'appelle very
good trip du nom de son émission et
c'est un enfant de la Vallée de
Chevreuse imaginez-vous donc il va venir
de rester très attachée à ça il a grandi
dans la vallée des Chevreuse il restait
très attaché à sa maison d'enfance il y
vient souvent il va nous parler de son
nouveau livre et puis de la saison de
l'été prochain sur France Inter très
intéressante passionn ant et bien vous
retrouver la semaine prochaine bah avec
plaisir Régine merci à très vite et
l'émission touche bientôt à sa fin juste
avant de vous de nous quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil brillera dans
tout le département côté température il
fera 10 degrés à Rambouillet et Houdan
et 11 degrés à Versailles et mentent la
jolie et dans l'après-midi ça se dégrade
un peu le ciel sera partagé entre ciel
et entre nuages et soleil sur tout le
territoire côté température prévoyait 18
degrés en moyenne sur tout le
département et demain on fêtera la fin
Donatien
et ça y est c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une très belle soirée et
sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]